let's tackle a slightly harder problem
than what we saw in the last video I
have here X minus three over X plus 4 is
greater than or equal to two
so the reason why this is slightly
harder is I now have a greater than or
equal to and the other thing that makes
it slightly harder is I don't just have
a simple 0 here I actually have a 2 here
so let's I'm going to do this problem
the same way I'm going to do it two ways
I'm going to do the same two ways we did
last time but I'm going to reverse the
order of the two ways that I do it so
the first thing I can do I might be
tempted let me multiply both sides of
this equation times X plus 4 and like we
saw in the last video we have to be very
careful because we have an inequality
here if X plus 4 is greater than 0
then we're going to keep the inequality
the same if it's less than 0 we're going
to swap it so let's look at those two
situations so one situation is let me
make it right here one situation is X
plus 4 is greater than 0 and remember it
can never be equal to 0 because then
this expression would be undefined so
let's explore X plus 4 is greater than 0
if we subtract 4 from both sides of this
equation this is equivalent to saying
these are equivalent statement if we
subtract 4 from both sides that X is
greater than minus 4 so if we assume
that X is greater than minus 4 then X
plus 4 is going to be greater than 0 and
then when we multiply both sides of this
times X plus 4 let's do that X minus 3
over X plus 4 you have your 2 we're
going to multiply both sides of this
times X plus 4 times X plus 4 since
we're assuming X is greater than minus 4
or that X plus 4 is greater than 0 we
don't have to switch the inequality sign
right we're multiplying both sides by a
positive so the inequality stays the
same as in our original problem and the
whole reason why we did that is because
this and this will cancel out and then
we have 2 times X plus 4 let's see what
we get we get X minus 3 is greater than
or equal to 2 times X plus 2 times 4
which is 8 and now what can we do we can
subtract X from both sides we get minus
3 is greater than or equal to
X plus 8 right I just took X from 2x and
then we can subtract 8 from both sides
so you should attract 8 from both sides
you get minus 3 minus 8 is minus 11 is
greater than or equal to X and of course
if we subtract an 8 so this guy
disappears so if we assume that X is
greater than minus 4 then X has to be
less than or equal to minus 11 now that
seems a little bit a little bit
nonsensical right if in order for this
statement to be true X has to be both
greater than minus 4 and it has to be
less than minus 11 anything greater than
minus 4 is going to be a greater than
minus 11 so there's no X that satisfies
this equation right if so if we assume
that X plus 4 is greater than 0 we just
get up and we just end up with a
nonsensical solution so we can actually
ignore we can ignore that path there's
no situation in which X plus 4 is going
to be greater than 0 and we're going to
actually have a solution to this
equation so let's assume what happens
when X plus 4 is less than 0 I'll do it
here maybe so what happens when X plus 4
is less than 0 and once again that's an
equivalent statement if we subtract 4
from both sides of this equation just
saying that X is less than minus 4 these
are equivalent statements so if we
assume that X is less than minus 4 then
when we multiply both sides of this
equation times X plus 4 so you have X
plus 4 and you're multiplying it by X
minus 3 over X plus 4 and all of that
and you have your 2 and you're
multiplying that times X plus 4 since
we're taking the other situation where X
is less than minus 4 which makes this
expression negative since we're
multiplying both sides of the equation
by a negative we swap the inequality we
swap the inequality just like that and
let's see what we get this and this
cancel out and then we get X minus 3 is
less than or equal to 2 times X plus 2
times 4 which is 8
and we do the same algebra let's
subtract let's subtract X from both
sides we get minus 3 is less than or
equal to X plus 8 if we subtract 8 from
both sides we get minus 11 is less than
or equal to X so if we assume so this
this is interest so if X if we assume
this is negative we get X has to be less
than minus 4 if X is less than minus 4
in order for this equation to hold up X
also has to be greater than minus 11 and
this is actually possible you can have
an X so X has to be we can rewrite this
greater than or equal to minus 11 I just
swap the two sides and X has to be less
than minus 4 and there are X's that
satisfy these two constraints there
weren't X's that satisfy these two
constraints nothing satisfies both of
these but there are things that satisfy
both of these for example minus 5 so
let's draw this on the number line let's
draw our solution to our to this problem
and we keep the problem there and if I
draw a number line I want to switch
colors so we have minus 11 we can be
greater than or equal to minus 11 so
this is minus 11 and then we have minus
4 over here we have minus 4 over here
maybe 0 sitting over there we have to be
less than minus 4 remember we can never
be equal to minus 4 because that would
make this undefined so we have to be
less than minus 4 so we don't include
minus 4 we're less than minus 4 but we
have to be greater than or equal to 11
so we can't go less than 11 but we
include the 11 because this was greater
than or equal to so anything in this
where I've shaded it in anything on this
range will satisfy that equation over
there now let's do it the other way
let's do it where we logic or they
either have to be the numerator
denominator both have to be positive or
negative let's see if we can do that the
same problem that way so let me rewrite
it down here maybe in a new color so the
same problem X minus 3 over X plus 4
greater than or equal to two now in
order to do that reasoning that I did in
the first video remember the first video
I said well if a divided by B is greater
than zero either both of these are
positive or both of these are negative
but this only worked when we had a zero
over here but we don't have a zero here
we have a two so we can't at least
immediately do that rationale but maybe
we can if we subtract two from both
sides of this equation so let's do that
so you have X minus three over X plus
four minus 2 is greater than or equal to
zero just subtracted two from both sides
don't have you know I can add or
subtract without messing up the
inequality never have to worry about
that it's only when you multiply by
negatives that you swap the inequality
and now what is this you know this
doesn't look like a rational expression
but I can rewrite minus 2 right minus 2
minus 2 is the same thing as minus 2
times X plus 4 over X plus 4 all right
this is minus 2 times 1 this is the same
thing and this is the same thing as
minus 2 X plus let me be careful this is
the same thing as minus 2 X minus 8
right over X plus 4 this right here is
the exact same thing as minus 2 right I
just multiply it times X plus 4 over X
plus 4 let's write it this way because
then we can add them so if we write it
that way so I have X minus 3 over X plus
4 and I wrote it that way to have a
common denominator and then I have plus
minus 2x minus 8 over X plus 4 is
greater than 0 I have a common
denominator that was my whole point of
doing this and so I have a denominator
of x plus 4 and then when you add these
two things you get X minus 2 X that's
minus X and then you have minus 3 minus
8 that's minus 11 is greater than 0 so
now I've simplified the problem into
something like this so there's two
situations oh let me be very careful I
lost the this was greater than or equal
this must be greater than or equal this
is greater than or equal don't want to
lose
little equal signer that was the whole
point of this problem so now I'm ready
to operate it on on just like this so
let's actually before I even do this
let's get one thing out of the way let's
be very clear X can never be equal to
minus 4 right because if X is equal to
minus 4 this whole statement that
original problem is undefined so let's
just write that first you know we could
have written that from the get-go X
cannot be equal to minus 4 for any
solution that will make this expression
undefined now we have this and we saw in
the first video and we saw right there
that there's two situations either both
of these are positive so they're either
both positive so X minus X minus 11 is
greater than or equal to 0 right this
could be equal to 0 if actually if this
is equal to 0 then this whole thing is
going to be true so either that is
greater than or equal to 0 and this
right here is greater than 0 it can't be
equal to 0 and X plus 4 is greater than
0 that's the situation where both of
them are positive or or they're both
going to be less than 0 and I'm running
out of space or minus X minus 11 is less
than or equal to 0 and all right and
like that and X plus 4 is less than 0
remember can't ever equal 0 so they're
either both positive or both negative
that's the only way that we're going to
get something well the numerator can be
equal to 0 because this thing can equal
0 or they're both positive to get
something positive or they're both
negative so that when you divide a
negative by negative you still get
something positive so let's look at
these two situations and see if we get
any solutions that make sense so right
here if we add X to both sides of this
equation we get minus 11 is greater than
or equal to X or another way you could
say it is X is less than or equal to
minus 11 right I just swapped these two
sides and then here if we add minus 4 if
we subtract 4 from both sides we get X
is greater than X is greater than minus
4 but once again this makes it
there's no way that I can have remember
there's an end here both of these have
to be true there is no X that is greater
than minus 4 and less than minus 11 so
this this right here there's no
constraints that so both of these can
never be both the numerator denominator
can never both be positive at the same
time because in order for them both to
be positive you get an impossible
constraint to fill so let's look at this
situation the other situation is when
they are both negative when both this
numerator and this denominator are both
negative all right let me be clear these
two I didn't you can't make a statement
about these two not being positive these
two things can never be positive
remember because we had to get the zero
here in order to use this logic to begin
with so the fact that when we try to
figure out X's that would make both of
these positive we got a nonsensical
impossible to fill constraint tells me
that both this numerator and this
denominator can never both be positive
for any given X now let's see if they
can both be negative so for both of them
to be negative or the numerator could
also be equal to 0 if we add X to both
sides of this we get minus 11 is less
than or equal to X or we could say that
X is greater than or equal to minus 11
just swapping them around over here if
we subtract 4 from both sides we have X
is less than minus 4 and and this is an
an so X has to be greater than or equal
to minus 11 or less than minus 4 which
is exactly what we came up in the last
problem and we can draw the number line
again we have to be greater than or
equal to minus 11 so that's minus 11
there we could be equal to it or greater
than but we have to be less than minus 4
so this is minus 4 we can't even be
equal to minus 4 that will make our
denominator undefined or our holy
equation undefined it'll make our
denominator 0 and so this is our
solution set anything right here that I
have shaded in including minus 11 but
not including minus 4 so if you could
get this problem you I think you can
handle pretty much any rational any
rational equation problem hope you
enjoyed that